quel gimmick de merde j'ai instauré et
ben on va au bout des choses
fred sabrer dit pourquoi nous les tuons
sort toujours instaurer des limites qui
en plus ne nous plaisent jamais même les
uns trop regarder aujourd'hui de plus
aucun youtuber ne sait quoi faire en un
trou de ces vidéos se vient juste des
moments gênants collègues youtuber je
propose une trêve
arrêtons de nous forcer à rythmes moi
j'arrête la preuve j'aurais que tu es ce
moment-là de la vidéo comme ensuite il
après une année que j'arrive encore à
trouver des subsides qui me font vibrer
qui me font passer par des émotions et
bien écoutez je me posais cette question
et je n'ai pas la réponse mais qu au
fusil c'est le nom de ce président
aujourd'hui je suis petit ou grand qu'un
seul bris dit sur ce sujet là à savoir
les photos ou vidéos ou la perspective
est étrange et du coup de tucson le
cerveau finalement c'est un truc qui se
fait depuis longtemps il ya même des
vidéos très connus qui sont basés sur sa
sur la perspective
on croit savoir où sont placés les
objets les éléments d'une photo au
premier regard mais en fait on s'est
trompé et comment se rendre compte on
passe en mode squeeze et 2013 ont fait
heureux de ce à quoi
under ou neuf autres allez c'est parti
préparez vous à faire vraiment de feu
kobo de foot il a plongé
alors non mais là les effets spéciaux ya
pas de photomontages [ __ ] mais qu'ils
ont inversé verticalement la vidéo est
ce qu'on croit être les vrais arbres en
faut en fait c'est le reflet des arbres
dans l'eau et ce qu'ils ont découvert sa
part est rare et ce qu'ils ont filmée
ils ont regardé la vidéo comme ça dans
le mauvais sens ils ont fait un numéro 9
à quoi ou de boeck
je suis chiant ne jamais mettre des
vêtements de la même couleur que ta
chaise à la télé un mec ça le rend
tellement kidari on dirait moi moche et
méchant mais bon y'a plein de fois j'ai
mis un chat non mais ça va pas marcher
parce que je suis trop stock d'or piper
stock je dépasse de la chaise on la voit
pas il a fallu qu'il soit plus tôt crois
que ça soit en fait avez vous vu le
nouveau portail vert hogwarts en chine
ah ah non là par contre à wau caisse ici
j'ai c'est bon c'est marrant c'est les
perspectives d'un coup de ton cerveau
bascule est à la bonne vision des choses
et dakota la mauvaise le mec film juste
d'un toit et ça en fait que ya là c'est
le toit salle à cette partie là est
beaucoup plus haute que cette partie là
en fait juste un ça marche vraiment fort
et l'amex et des perspectives mais c'est
fou moi je croyais que ça allait être
les trucs c'est un ex label so good
ab c'est horrible c'est encore une image
qui a été tourné ça vous m'aurez pas
aller tous ensemble à 30 ont tous la
tête de 45 degrés vers la gauche
1 2 3 oui ça vous amuse de faire ce
genre d'image qui font peur à des gens
j'aurais honte à votre place
non moi je suis jaloux j'aimerais avoir
des bonnes idées comme ça et créer des
images trop cool qui jugera perspective
je croyais que didier callède venait
d'obtenir son diplôme
mdr c'est vrai qu'au premier regard on
dirait c'était drôle dahang rempart
contre le mythe s'écroule
qu'on soit clair une pierre censuré
watts
ouais on dirait une pixellisation
naturel mais qu attendait ouais d'accord
que si vous avez eu cette impression là
que c'était une pierre censuré vous avez
regardé beaucoup trop de choses sur
internet qu'il fallait pas regarder on
est d'accord avec ça ça restera entre
nous les autres oubliés oublier ce que
je veux dire c'est drôle mais sa tête va
si bien avec son bras à à château c'est
vraiment génial qu'un c'est pas un mec a
fait exprès de faire une photo et de la
mettre dans l'autre sens pour qu'on
croie des trucs mais quand c'est juste
un gars qui a pris une photo comme ça au
plus et il a regardé deux jours plus
tard et la fema tomber nommez-moi de
haut niveau qui tue voilà l'antithèse
parfait photo suivante c'est l'antithèse
parfaite de ce que j'aime bien c'était
le genre de photo qu'avait 38000 j'aime
en 2013 mais un 2010 avec bien sûr les
gens évolué et les gens aiment autre
chose
[Musique]
you avec cette vieille carte mère
ressemble à un temple égyptien
arthur et les minimoys ça existe ok ça
exige les toujours su à l'époque je le
disais autour de moi on se moque et la
vérité éclate aujourd'hui ok ça c'est un
délai avec tête on fera un jour une
vidéo sur la macrophoto c'est absolument
génial
enfin julien il ya vraiment un monde
invisible autour de nous qu'on voit pas
quoi
quelle personne odieuse mon frère singes
[Musique]
par contre c'est vers son pied mais
d'accord regardez le bas de cette cage
d'escalier dans l'impression de regarder
un couloir
waouh ya eu un grattage de crâne l'aca a
fait chauffer les neurones c'est génial
là il ya un vrai délire artistique c'est
vraiment bon qu en plus ça ferait un
hôtel qui est vraiment cool genre on
dirait vraiment un hôtel de luxe tout
c'est trop beau la squad des choses non
ça marche pas du tout je suis désolé
chez bien stop je suis obligé de mettre
un stop
ces notes c'est horrible ce comportement
je n'apporte rien du tout à ces abris
dit n'apporte aucune image cool aucun
truc qui je sors perspective juge le
juge je suis vraiment un con j'ai reçu
sa part mail j'ai cru que cet enfant
était en train de flex et non il fait
quoi à être c'est très lourd avec un
bras un peu bizarre disproportionné par
rapport à son corps c'était vous fait
des pubs et que vous les envoyer par
mail gérait bien vos perspectives
j'aimerais bien vos perspectives de vie
aussi ce cadeau cette morale nul achats
qui a les courbes d'un oiseau alors là
je fus cet accord mais c'est totalement
un corbeau tu as domestique et un
corbeau et c'est tout à ton honneur mais
assume ne dis pas que c'est un champion
on dirait un corbeau c'est la faute à la
faute au nord tu aimes les corbeaux
assume
hu hu c'est fou alors là on ne peut
qu'apprécier l'artiste qui a fait ce
petit espace d'herbe incroyable ça fait
penser au street art parfois il ya une
mue par terre et quand tu la regardes un
certain angle c'est une illusion
d'optique de malades cela s'ajoute la
perspective quoi exactement comme ce qui
est sûr ce serait dit sauf que là c'est
pas juste de la peinture servent les
espaces derme c'est fou bravo aux
premières vidéos du sob sleeping
perspective
what de feu mandé qui a vaincu leur
foncent dessus allez à aa
franchement ça se fait pas mais qu'est
ce gaz et le rôle alors on ne s'est pas
compliqué on se fait que camus il danse
en fait il en train de faire remorquer
c'est ça oui je crois que c'est ça oui
il en train de faire tirer parce qu'il
est en panne mais du coup ça peut faire
peur dans une situation si tu devrais
compte réveille en criant comme 6ème un
accident il est vrai ne fait pas ses
blagues à vos copains c'est pas sympa
les vaches sont longues en france
oh ça parle d'un paysage classique
classique mais on aime une nouvelle
journée un nouvel écureuils de cinq
mètres qui essaient de rentrer dans la
voiture de ma mère ouais mais ça
m'empêche pas d'avoir envie de descendre
le cas et c'est vraiment ça me fait peur
à aucun moment ces adorables
j'aimerais qu'ils aient plus écureuil
géant ses cheveux sont une fac in using
conjuguée à l'avant ce poster
alors c'est ça les techniques en 2019
pour cacher sa grosse calvasse c'est de
toujours se mettre devant quelqu'un qui
a les cheveux longs c'est bien trouvé
bravo je vais appliquer ce conseil
désormais cette église ressemble un
poulet stop à l'air est-ce que vous
suivez les vidéos ou non est ce que
cette image se trouve sur le bon sobre
et dit non ça doit aller dans le sobre
et dit paré et dolly qui vous pouvez
retrouver dans cette magnifique vidéo
sorti il ya déjà plusieurs mois très
divertissante et sympathique elle ne
joue pas du tout sur les perspectives
elle joue sur le fait que notre cerveau
a tendance à relier une image un visage
voila je viens de hyper mal expliqué
appareils de rim et je l' ai bien
expliqué dans cette vidéo là alors ils
jonglent tellement vite avec les cigares
boxe on a l'illusion qu'il ya trois mois
ah ouais
[Musique]
wow c'est que tu caches à troisième bras
on a vu ça existe à trois bras pour le
coup pour gagner ta vie c'est vraiment
ce truc là qu'il faut faire tout ce
qu'on trois bras ici peuvent témoigner
c'est parce que vous croyez
[Musique]
si si si si si c'est bien ce qu'on croit
c'est bien ce qu'on croit plus mais le
bras dans le dos les gens quand je
prends une photo avec thé très tactile
c'est bien ce qu'on croit ouais ça me
fin qui est ce que l'esprit mal placé
intervient dans ce bris de vous en
pensez quoi
oui évidemment au waou là j'ai vraiment
cru quelque chose je ne dirais pas mais
j'ai vraiment cru
ah oui oui et oui la tête de mais je
comprends pas où peut être sa tête à lui
hawass et mon jeu léo alors là mais
qu'il est légendaire niveau légendaire
en gros ça je croyais que c'était la
tête de quelqu'un mais en fait c'est la
tête de l'enfant qu'elle a jusque là et
on voit juste le nez et la bouche dans
la tête du père qui dépasse on dirait
que ces normes se trouve vous l'avez
tous pour cela pas la voir une fois de
plus je me fais humilié dans une de mes
propres vidéos euros le président c'est
drôle
au nom de la démo n'est fait mais
attendez youtube c'est qu'une illusion
c'est le thème de la vidéo c'est laid ça
joue sur les perspectives des illusions
quoi bon elle n'est pas vraiment mort la
femme n'y a pas de sens rendez moi mon
argent je suis en forme à cette fin
aladin a perdu sur tapis elle génial
celle là lomu du drapeau est tellement
bon endroit
c'est flou c'est ouf quand même quand tu
mets la photo on augmente arrive pas à
trop tirer l'idée n'arrivent pas à
changer sa manière de voir les choses
alors c'est évident que c'est parce que
tu crois même temps j'ai envie de croire
que c'est ce que je crois que c'est où
ça devient chiant mais c'est la même
chose c'est exactement la même chose que
notre photo est ce que c'est les mêmes
gens et ils s'amusent tout le temps vers
cette [ __ ] de photos la 7e à la vache
arrêtez de mettre des bobs s'il vous
plaît ça casse les cerveaux et bien
écoutez je dois admettre que c'est l'un
des sabres est dit sur lesquels j'ai
pris le plus de plaisir c'est un truc
très générique qui plaît à tout le monde
les illusions d'optique les délires de
perspectives et je suis très content
qu'ils aient un ce brésil sur ça parce
que vraiment je suis fan
j'adore et ya des mécaniques que j'ai
jamais vue comme celle avec le bob c'est
le traumatisme avec moi quand je vais
voir des bocks je vais me méfier je vais
regarder ailleurs je vais baisser les
yeux en tout cas quand c'est des gens
qui volontairement joue sur les
perspectives et font des photos avec ça
street art par exemple dans la rue tout
ça vraiment vraiment cool en tout cas
moi je suis très sensible à ça ça me
fait beaucoup d'effet euros allez je
vous dis à bientôt ses prochaines vidéos
jeux laquelle vous aura plu bye bye
original
[Musique]